m
[Applaudissements]
bourbeau base va
pas de sa vie tour bahrénien
balgau des vaches a dit mme hayes diona
pacho d'aia
[Musique]
ça c'est l'idée que vous faites du yoga
non ou bien peut-être que c'est ça
l'image que vous avez dit mot yoga c'est
le constat que je fais lorsque je dis
que je pratique le yoga
car la plupart du temps les personnes en
face de moi me répondent
waouh tu dois être super souple qu'on se
le dise tout de suite touché ses pieds
quand on se penche en avant ça a un nom
la souplesse mais ça ne s'appelle pas
yoga le yoga est né en inde
il est entre 2000 et 5000 ans l'occident
s'est approprié depuis quelques
décennies cette pratique ancestrale
on compte 300 millions de yogi à travers
le monde et ils sont 2,5 millions en
france à pratiquer le yoga de manière
régulière ou occasionnelle
une étude menée en 2010 est auprès des
pratiquants français montre que pour la
moitié d'entre eux le yoga participent à
leur bonne hygiène de vie un tiers
aspire à se sentir bien dans leur corps
et recherche des effets relaxants et
antistress lorsque l'on interroge les
pratiquants pour connaître la raison qui
les a amenés à commencer le yoga on
trouve un point commun entre toutes les
raisons qui sont avancés ce point commun
c'est la recherche d'un apaisement face
à une souffrance ça peut être une
douleur physique douleur bien souvent
chronique dans le corps est derrière un
médecin ou un proche qui a conseillé de
faire du yoga pour atténuer cette
douleur ou bien une douleur
psychologique un sentiment de mal-être
ou encore le stress par lequel on se
sent parfois dépassés c'est alors le
besoin de reprendre confiance en soi ou
de prendre du temps pour soi qui
recherchait à travers la pratique du
yoga
il existe plusieurs formes de yoga
certaines formes sont dynamiques comme
le vinyasa yoga d'autres requièrent
immobilité c'est le cas du yin yoga
chacun peut trouver un yoga qui lui
correspond dans tous les cas ce qui est
recherché en yoga c'est
l'interdépendance du corps et de
l'esprit
l'esprit c'est la clé dans ces yoga
posturaux on réalise différentes
postures comme par exemple celle ci mais
il ya quelque chose que l'on ne voit pas
sur cette photo
d'ailleurs sur cette photo de nanas avec
son corps parfait ça super tenu à 160
euros
non mais parce que vous savez c'est
devenu ça la réalité du yoga moderne un
business bien rodée qui vient de plus en
plus cher et donc de plus en plus
élitiste le yoga c'est devenu également
quelque chose dans lequel il faut
performer s'afficher sur les réseaux
sociaux est souvent dans des postures
acrobatique
c'est une véritable ironie ça va aux
antipodes de ce que l'on apprend au yoga
traditionnel en yoga il n'y a pas de
compétition même envers soi même dans
une salle de yoga
il n'y a pas de miroir face auxquels on
pourrait se tenir et se scrutent et on
s'est fait rattraper par tous les
polluants de la vie moderne s'évaluer et
se comparer aux autres cherchent à
atteindre des objectifs de performance
paraître plus beau plus fort plus
épanouie même que les autres tout ce que
l'on cherche à fuir par une pratique du
yoga ci devenue la vitrine du yoga
actuelle mais bon je disais sur cette
photo il ya quelque chose que l'on ne
voit pas et qui est véritablement
important yoga c'est la respiration
on respire 22 mille fois par jour pour
les yogis nous naissons avec un nombre
prédéfini de respiration ainsi en
maîtrisant sa respiration
on vivrait plus vieux afin que vous
puissiez prendre conscience de
l'importance de votre respiration au
delà du simple fait de vous tenir en vie
évidemment je vous invite à placer vos
mains sur votre ventre
allez-y placez vos mains sur votre
ventre
à peu près au niveau du nombril c'est
très bien redresser vous un petit peu
voilà on s'installe bien au fond de son
siège ont des temps les épaules vos
lèvres sont closes et votre mâchoire
détendue d'abord vous expirez
profondément par le nez on expire
toujours par le nez au yoga avant de
commencer une inspiration afin de faire
de la place dans ses poumons et
maintenant vous inspirez profondément
par le nez et santé comme vos mains se
soulèvent légèrement expiré par le nez
vos mains sa baisse vous pouvez aussi ne
pas sentir vos mains bouger alors
imaginez les se soulever et s'abaisser
au rythme de votre respiration
nous allons faire trois cycles
respiratoires ensemble et pour cela je
vous invite à fermer les yeux
on a bien les yeux fermés bien installé
fermez les yeux
les mains sur votre ventre terminez
votre respiration actuelle en expirant
profondément par le nih et sans forcer
inspiré par le nez vos mains se
soulèvent expiré par le nez vos mains sa
baisse inspiré par le nih vos mains se
baisse inspiré par le nih expiré par le
nih rester dans cet état
servat sion ne vous occupez plus de
votre respiration et observer comment
quelques instants vous sentez relax et
apaisée et doucement vous allez pouvoir
rouvrir les yeux au yoga on inspire et
on expire par le nez j'ai beaucoup
insisté sur ce mot le nez dans
l'exercice que l'on vient de faire
ensemble
mais c'est volontaire l'air inspiré par
le nez et mis en contact au niveau des
sinus avec un gaz qui s'appelle l'oxydé
nitrique l'air inspiré par le nez et
plus concentrés en ce gaz que si on
avait respirer par la bouche
l'intérêt d'avoir une forte
concentration en oxyde nitrique
c'est que ce gaz intervient dans le
fonctionnement du système nerveux
c'est ça que vous avez pu ressentir dans
le petit exercice que l'on vient de
faire ensemble
cette sensation de calme l'air inspiré
par le nez et plus concentrés en ce gaz
que si on avait inspiré par la bouche
l'intérêt d'avoir une forte
concentration en oxyde nitrique
c'est que ce gaz intervient dans le
fonctionnement de régulation de notre
attitude face à un stress indirectement
l'oxydé nitrique intervient au sein de
notre cerveau et nous offre quelques
secondes de plus dans une situation
stressante
ces quelques secondes seront utilisés
afin de mieux analyser la situation et
d'agir de manière plus réfléchie en
répétant la respiration nasale
à chaque fois que l'on pratique on met
en place des automatismes dans le corps
ses automatismes s'ancrant nous perdure
au delà du tapis et sont utilisés
inconsciemment dans notre vie
quotidienne
une bonne respiration peut soulager des
douleurs notamment dorsale calmer
l'esprit masse et les organes et
améliorer la digestion renforcer le
système immunitaire
aperçoit aujourd'hui par la science que
les yogis avait compris de manière
intuitive l'importance de la respiration
les yogis conçoivent la respiration
comme une force que nous puisons hors de
nous cette force
il l'appelle le prana le prana est une
énergie vitale et subtile qui imprègne
tout et que les êtres vivants absorbe
par l'air qu'ils inspirent si l'on s'en
tient à l'aspect mécanique les postures
que l'on fait en yoga permettent d'avoir
un corps tonique de dénouer des tensions
musculaires d'apaiser des douleurs
articulaires
mais ce qui compte avant tout ça n'est
pas de réussir la posture c'est de
ressentir l'effet de la posture sur son
corps et sur son esprit réaliser des
postures de yoga c'est surtout
s'observer pas se regarder fasse un
miroir se regarder de l'intérieur sait
écouter ses sensations physiques c'est
observer ses émotions
par exemple la satisfaction qu'on
éprouve lorsqu'on réussit une posture ou
au contraire la frustration qu'on a
lorsqu'on échoue en s'entraînant sur son
tapis à se mettre face à ses difficultés
et à ses réussites on devient plus
attentifs à ce que l'on ressent
simplement en observant ses émotions
on prend de la hauteur du recul sur ce
qu'elle suscite en nous et cela même sur
les émotions négatives
celle qui nous minent le moral dans
notre quotidien l'observation et la
respiration nous permettent de mieux
gérer les situations stressantes
comme par exemple un embouteillage rien
qu'à l'évocation de ce mot certains
d'entre vous ressentent une petite
bouffée de stress n'est ce pas une
voiture devant une voiture derrière on
est coincé plein de manières de réagir
s'offre à nous certains vont s'énerver
se stresser et arrive au travail dans un
état d'énervement qui aura un impact
négatif sur leurs collègues et de la
même manière le soir sur leur entourage
sans
relais des effets négatifs sur leur
santé d'autres au contraire sont
capables de ne pas s'énerver
peut-être parce qu'ils sont conscients
qu'ils n'ont pas prise sur cette
situation
cette deuxième manière d'aborder un
embouteillage ou toute autre situation
face à laquelle nous pouvons ressentir
un excès d'émotion est d'autant plus
facile à adopter que si on a déjà en où
les automatismes offert par le yoga mais
si ça n'est pas le cas on peut
s'observer sentir la pression monter et
consciemment réagir en tentant un
exercice de respiration
mais d'ailleurs les embouteillages
est-ce véritablement une situation
stressante la situation en elle même ne
l'est pas vraiment roulé au ralenti
ce n'est pas un stress en soit être
coincé dans un embouteillage peut avoir
des conséquences plus ou moins graves
mais si elles ne le sont pas est il
bénéfique de s'énerver je suis allé en
inde
dernièrement j'avais envie d'aller voir
aux sources de ce qu'est le yoga pour
voir comment il est vécu comment il est
pratiqué dans les textes fondateurs
les sages yogi nous font part
d'expériences d'immobilité méditative
je suis donc parti durant un mois et
cette méditation dont tout le monde nous
dit le plus grand bien
je me suis dit qu'après plusieurs années
de pratique de yoga
après un mois entier à faire cela que
j'allais enfin pouvoir y arriver à
m'asseoir en tailleur et à faire le vide
et bien non ça a été frustrant
j'étais
presque en colère contre moi même de ne
pas y arriver face à la méditation
j'avais réussi à mettre la pression et à
ressentir un sentiment d'échec
tout ce que j'avais appris grâce au yoga
qu'il fallait mieux être indulgent
envers soi même
au lieu de tenter de se forcer je
n'avais pas réussi à l'appliquer
j'avais cette image du med-it en asie'
immobile paisible durant des heures et
je voulais atteindre moi aussi cet état
de perfection mais concrètement quand je
méditais j'avais beau me forcer mon
corps me faisait mal mes pensées
vagabondent et et je finissais par me
lever excédé ce qui s'était passé c'est
que j'avais simplement oublié une chose
observé
si mon corps me faisait mal à rester
assis il était en train de faire passer
un message
il fallait que je me lève je quitte
cette posture assise qui m'était si
inconfortable mais c'est tout a ajouté
un jugement de valeur
celui de me sentir nul était totalement
inutile et si le yoga c'était simplement
cela s'observer sans jugement à partir
de là je me suis mise à pratiquer plus
ouvertement face à ce que je ressens je
ferme les yeux et je me demande de quoi
j'ai envie
j'écoute et j'observe j'écoute sans
valider j'écoute sans rejeter j'écoute
sans me dire que c'est acquis j'accepte
les joues rougies arrive et ce je n'y
arrive pas je n'avais pas compris que la
méditation comme tant d'autres choses
survient mais ne se contrôle pas la
méditation mais aussi comme on l'a vu
tout à l'heure les posture la
respiration l'observation font partie
des étapes qui mènent à l'éveil réussir
à quitter son tapis de yoga en emportant
avec soin ce qu'on a appris nous ouvre
des perspectives en prenant le temps de
servez on apprend à se découvrir on
apprend à mieux se connaître
quand on accède à une meilleure
connaissance de soi
il est plus facile de se comprendre
il est plus facile de s'accepter tel que
l'on est
et de prendre les bonnes décisions
celles qui sont bénéfiques pour nous
mêmes et pas l'un vers ce et comme une
évidence
mieux se comprendre et mieux se
connaître nous permet de mieux
comprendre les autres et peut-être même
de les accepter tels qu'ils sont le yoga
est une démarche personnelle
individuelle qui a un retentissement
extraordinaire sur le monde qui nous
entoure et dans l'autre sens le yoga
mourant plus ouvert plus attentifs aux
bruissements du monde
il nous rend plus empathique
il nous rend plus bienveillant il nous
aide à changer
merci
[Applaudissements]